[Music]
a
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud proud and do not give
a
[Music]
[__] this this is the Tony Michaels
podcast real and raw political and
social commentary the freedom to oppress
the rights of other people is not
Liberty you [__] eating [__] ah the
smell of freedom of speech this is the
Tony Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them
he's not mad at BB
Netanyahu other
than BBE I don't know is appreciative of
an American president who gets up in the
morning does his [__] job like an
adult isn't a [__]
child also there's a there's a clip of
Donald Trump welcome toy Tony Michaels
podcast by the way it is Thursday
October
12th noon
Eastern here in
America and we're going to be talking
about Donald Trump praising
Hezbollah and Hamas and attacking
Benjamin
Netanyahu the Israeli Prime Minister as
you know I mean I have plenty of
disagreements with BB Netanyahu but it
is funny to watch the crybaby Donald
Trump attack what he would view as his
best friend ever in the history of ever
but really this beef with BB Netanyahu
hearkens back all the way to
2020 there's a clip I'm gonna show it to
you of Donald Trump on the speaker phone
with Netanyahu trying to get him to call
Joe Biden sleepy Joe now what Donald
Trump didn't know in that moment that BB
knew is that BB knew that Joe Biden was
probably gonna be
president just like he is now and he's
an adult and he's doing the thing that
adults do when you're the leader of the
Free
World is to be a leader not a [__]
crybaby like Donald Trump a lot of
people are saying that oh my God this is
going to be the last straw for Donald
Trump get the [__] out of here they were
cheering him and clapping him they're
praising him today what makes you think
this Colt is gonna leave him I'm telling
you there is no lowest of the low and it
is kind of funny because again I posted
yesterday that Maga is America's Hamas
like I tweeted that and people were kind
of upset at me some people said it was
too far that I should delete it and I
didn't and the reason why I didn't is
because of what the videos I'm gonna
show you today of
trump I I don't know how else to put it
MAA is America's
Hamas I mean you could say Hezbollah you
could say Isis you could say Taliban
Al-Qaeda I mean there's all kinds of
[__] terrorist groups that you could
equate with MAA and couldn't you huh
they use lie they use propaganda they
use fear they use violence to get their
point across am I right I'm going to
show you a couple examples of
today not
only not only uh is Donald Trump with
Hezbollah now he's sighting with
Hezbollah oh my
god oh Jesus [__] Christ oh man and
and if you're not aware of who Hezbollah
is Hezbollah is the terrorist group in
Lebanon that sides with Hamas and
Iran oops oops it's not that [__]
weird that Donald Trump would side with
terrorist organizations he runs one and
and he he backs terrorist murderous
dictators all around the world loves
[__]
Putin he Praises X as one of the smart
China X XII ping is one of the smartest
men in the entire world he loves
dictators he loves the North Korean dick
murderous dictator you remember you
remember the Philippines guy was just
[__] murdering his own people
remember that guy oh he loved him loved
him that's where he got the whole just
murder drug dealers thing
from that's where he got that from yeah
he [__] he [__] Lo he loves
fascist murderous dick dictators he he
wants to be one he tried to be one for
crying out loud he even got his violent
terrorist mob to come to our Capital try
to overthrow our government in a coup
attempt and you're mad because I say
that MAA is he is Hamas or hezb [__] out
of here okay good luck with that [__]
messaging oh oh MAA hasn't murdered
1,200 people yet yet that's the [__]
key word there yet you let them they
will I'm going to show you [__]
evidence this
morning these [__] M running
around our country this Insurgency
because it is they want to be violent
they want the members of manga to be
violent and they have pend it to
religion I showed you a clip the other
day of a woman in Iowa standing in line
waiting for her musolini Jesus to
emerge from the heavens of stupidity and
she says God sent Trump to save
America
and you don't see the connection between
1930s
Germany you don't see the connection
between a lot of the terrorist
organizations in the Middle East you
don't see it are you [__] kidding me
okay well it's at your own Peril then if
you're not willing to look at it and
admit and call it what it is speaking of
calling it what it is uh yesterday I
said Jim Jordan was going to be the
speaker of the house and it wasn't going
to be Steve skl the news came across
that Steve skl was going to be the
speaker of the house and then all of a
sudden that went over like a wet fart in
a white thong didn't it holy [__]
[__] Steve scalise you you you are such
a [__] loser you know and I'm so
happy that there's MAA that are finally
admitting the truth about Steve SC that
he's he's the David Duke without the
baggage Nancy mace literally went on
Trader TV news and was like yeah how how
the hell are we going to vote for a guy
who claims he's the David Duke with
without the baggage thanks Nancy M for
pointing out the facts that we've been
pointing out for
years but she's going to back Jim Jordan
Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan the
guy who looks the other way when there's
when his students are being sexually
molested by uh his colleagues huh in the
showers nonetheless in Ohio State I
wonder I wonder what it could be Nancy
mace bobert says she's gonna vote for
Marjorie Taylor green excuse me I mean
you might as well BT says she's going to
vote for Jim Jordan Marjorie Taylor
green says she's going to vote for Jim
Jordan they don't know how to govern and
the reason why they don't know how to
govern is because they're an
authoritarian they have only one person
that they have to please that's Donald
Trump don't you see they can't [__]
govern because they're not governing for
us they're governing for him and it's
not governing when it's for one
authoritarian I don't know if you know
that or not that isn't how our Republic
operates that's why they're so [__]
dysfunctional that's why they seem in
disarray because they don't know what we
are they don't know our system of
government and they're really trying to
use our democracy to destroy it but it's
not [__] working it's not working at
all because us the people we the people
the Democracy the Republic out here who
vote their asses in we voted in Joe
Biden and 81 million people didn't vote
for Joe Biden I I want to give you that
you know I I want to tell manga 81
million people didn't vote for Joe Biden
a lot of those 81 million voted against
your dumb [__] cult
leader who backs Hezbollah are you
[__] [__] me look I'm not a fan
of BB Netanyahu right and and you don't
have to be a fan of BB Netanyahu and the
road that he's taking Israel
down and have to [__] coddle [__]
Hamas and Hezbollah you do not have to
do those two things are not exclusive
you can actually you can actually say BB
Netanyahu he's got some right-wing
Tendencies he seems like a little bit of
a fasy right he's kind of leading Israel
down a road that doesn't smell like
democracy you know what I mean and you
can also say Hamas is a bunch of
murderous [__]
terrorists and they should go get those
[__] just like we went and got
Isis just like we went and got Osama Bin
Laden yes that's what that's what the
world should [__] do we shouldn't
tolerate [__] people murder people in
the name of [__] religion and Terror
it's just not something we should put up
with should we be bloodthirsty no we
don't have to be bloodthirsty over
it but what we should do is make a very
distinct statement here in the world
that we will not tolerate this type of
[__] rather it's there here wherever the
[__] it is if you're going to march
across a border a sovereign border and
murder women and children Putin you
[__] in Ukraine or H Hamas in
Israel then we're going to [__] do
something about it yeah we're going to
stand up for [__] human rights we're
going to stand up for the right of
people to [__] live you [__]
that's probably what we should do
especially when they're countries that
are democracies even if they're not
perfect democracies folks because we're
not a perfect democracy it's not a thing
perfect democracy does not
exist it won't exist we can get close
maybe but it's never are going to be
perfect and the reason why is because
it's a democracy that's kind of the
[__] point speaking of democracy and
not perfect oh my god did you hear who's
gonna run for
president tyt couldn't get Maryann
Williamson off the ground they can't
find anyone else to run for president
that'll win so now their [__] owner
or whatever the hell he is
they're Jen anger is gonna run for
president
a that's got to be a [__] joke
doesn't it seriously is that a [__]
joke can someone check and see if that's
all [__] and I mean it is [__]
he thinks he's going to run right and he
says he's going to take it to the
Supreme Court I really haven't looked
much into it to be perfectly honest with
you I just heard that he's gonna run for
president and I laughed and laughed and
laughed you're such a dumb you're such a
dumb [__] Jank you're such a dumb [__]
oh my God I can't tell you how
ridiculous this
is you lying piece of [__] you're always
lying to everyone everywhere for your
own [__] for your own [__] benefit
for your own [__] pocket for your own
[__]
grift you lied to the American people
you act you act as if that someone's
gonna challenge Joe Biden and when when
the truth comes to [__] smack you in
the face because people like me tell you
to [__] off and tell my audience and
tell people to stop listening to your
dumbass because you're a dumbass lying
piece of
[__] then you're just gonna you think
you're gonna run good good I hope it
destroys you to be quite honest with you
I hope it destroys your reputation I
hope it destroys the ability for you to
commentate seriously I hope it does
because that's what needs to happen in
this country we need to get rid of these
self- Dee [__] lying grifting pieces
of [__] I don't care what where they're
at what network they're on who the [__]
they are what ideology they have [__]
them [__] them [__] them [__] them it's
not of this [__] either stand with
democracy or you don't and if you're if
you're lying about to yourself or to
your viewers or to anyone else about how
our democracy works then you're not
standing with our democracy just like
yesterday when the Republicans decided
they were going to have a closed door
meeting to pick their speaker which is
not how it works folks hey let me give
you a clue that's not how it works
that's why Steve scal is not the speaker
yesterday after they had the meeting
they had to open the floor of the house
they had the floor open for two and a
half minutes two and a half minutes to
had the floor of the house open before
they went to recess just long enough to
go to recess because the Republicans
stepped on a
rake good [__] them let them keep steing
on stepping on rakes do not take the
shovel out of their hands when they are
digging their own political grave the
reason why they had a closed D meeting
yesterday and I told you this when was
happening is they didn't want Trump in
the room now here's how they tried to
keep Trump out of the room they had a
closed door meeting with no electronic
devices so no one could have Trump on
speaker phone barking orders to these
[__] that's what it was for it
didn't have anything to do with
recording the the what was going on in
the room or recording the vote [__] we
knew the vote we knew we knew Jim Jordan
got 99 votes coming out of that stupid
ass whatever the hell you want to call
it
show it's a [__] show is what it
is because their plan was to go to the
floor of the house 3 o'clock Eastern to
vote for Steve
scalise because they know they know the
only way they can keep Trump from
telling them what to do in the house are
owning the speaker hookline
Sinker is to get someone like Steve
scalise to 217 without Trump's backing
and they couldn't do it yesterday they
couldn't do it and it's not really I
mean they can't govern but the reason
why they can't govern is because the
Republican party is an authoritarian
dictor organization they're not for
democracy anymore they are not a
political party they are Hamas they are
Hezbollah they are Isis got it know it
Mark it down don't leave it trust me on
this doubt me if you want to doubt me
just [__] doubt me I'm gonna show you
videos of it today of of Steve scales
coming out of me he's like yeah oh man
oh so good oh man I can't wait to get to
the floor and
then wet fart in a white thong that's
how it went over yesterday for Steve
scalise and boy it couldn't happen to a
better guy oh Man the David Duke without
the bagage oh couldn't happen to a
better [__] let me tell you
Steve you piece of
[__] get your head on straight man pluck
your head out of your ass and understand
that you guys made this authoritarian
bed and you're going to sleep in it the
only person that's going to be the
speaker of the house is who Donald Trump
anoints he decided to go with Kevin
McCarthy when Kevin McCarthy wouldn't
shut the government down the way that he
wanted him to he got rid of him threw
Matt
gats to vacate him with one vote one
vote to
motion and they got rid of him
eight eight [__]
Republicans
and they want to blame it all this [__]
on the Democrats what the [__] are you
talking about there wasn't one Democrat
okay let me give you an idea of how much
this is not have anything to do with
Democrats there wasn't one [__]
Democrat in that room not one in that
[__] room with the Republican caucus
trying to figure out who the [__]
going to be the next dumb son of a [__]
that's going to lose their seat in
Congress because they're going to try to
be the Speaker of the House When Donald
Trump is actually the dictator of their
party that's how it works
that's how it's working folks this is
what authoritarianism does this is why
our country isn't it seems like we're
divided we're not divided that's all
[__] we only have one party
interested in [__] democracy only one
and that is tough when you are in a
two-party system to try to get [__] done
and try to govern that's why Washington
seems so disfunctional that's why
they've seem dun functional for two
decades three decades for crying out
loud
Republicans they don't know how to
govern because they don't believe in
democracy not only do they not want it
they don't believe in it they don't
believe that it is the tool that is
going to make them or help them Force us
to do what they want us to
do
period listen
folks the Germans tried to stay silent
in 1930 and I don't think we should
either so when I call Maga Hamas it's
you know we're in the moment right
they're also the
Taliban
Al-Qaeda y Qaeda if you want
to Y Qaeda y kaaa oh
Mar they're Isis they're Hezbollah and
really honestly Trump's telling you out
loud he's telling you this [__] out loud
literally yesterday he's saying it out
loud oh buddy what other news do we have
that we're going to go over holy [__] oh
by the way last night I want to thank
everyone who sent me great wishes last
night uh again it was Wednesday night so
I went and and I hung out with my
friends son karaoke drank some Jagger
Meister I sent you guys some pictures on
social media I want to thank a couple
people here uh for sending some
shots last night and I I took those
shots there's some pictures on social
media but everyone was sending great
wishes cheers so I want to say cheers to
everyone uh but it was who we got here
we got Cynthia Cynthia sent some Brooke
sent some thank you Brooke and Carol
also sent some shots last night this
morning to help me you know give me
energy for the show you know a lot of
people are like Tony you need to stop
drinking and I'm I don't drink that much
not really I mean one night a week
sometimes two and I have two three shots
it really is not that much I mean I'm
not going to lie to you sometimes I'm
hung over as [__] when I come up the
show and sometimes it's been because of
other things I partak in the night
before not exactly alcohol maybe
THC in the form of edible gummies but
you know that's how it goes that's how
it goes so I appreciate everyone um who
sent messages well messages yesterday
and cheers messages uh yesterday last
night when I sent some pictures of the
shots and the shots I was taking and I
appreciate Brooke Cynthia and Carol for
sending sending support in the way of
buying me shots and if you want to do
that if that's how you want to how you
want to enjoy the show you can do that
at the Tony michaels.com just hit
subscribe at the top of the Tony
michaels.com you can see the very most
current episode today's episode's at the
very top here's how you support the show
live if you want to buy me a shot if you
want to get in on the venmo Super Chat I
had a super chat from Anna yesterday um
she says I don't have to bring it up but
I probably will just because it goes
along with what I'm talking talking
about today hm who to know and then if
you want to add to the swear jar there's
the swear jar there too you can also
support us by being a member on patreon
or the Discord server or linking your
Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account don't forget if you have linked
your Twitch account to your Prime
account to go resubscribe on Twitch all
the directions are right here on how to
do all that on neony michaels.com and I
want to tell you there's some merch
links here for merch store and [__] them
hats and Gabe Sanchez's merch as well
but I want to tell you um we're going to
have some merch coming up soon uh for
the holiday season we got some great
ideas and we're g to we're going to put
them in the merch store so be looking
for that I got some exciting news to
show you and to give you on that so
that's going to be coming in the coming
weeks and I also want to talk about this
weekend if you want to enjoy karaoke
speaking of karaoke this weekend on
Sunday I haven't decided what time we
normally do the Sunday rants at 8
o'clock
but I'm thinking if we do the karaoke
we're probably going to do it earlier so
more people can join in because we got
fans all around the world and we're
actually G to do it on Twitch okay so
it'll be on
Twitch if you're listening it'll be on
Twitch um that's where we'll air it and
we'll also be in Discord they'll be
streaming it in Discord so go join the
Discord uh you're not going to want to
miss that and that's where the chat
party never stops over there on Discord
so I'll drop the I'll the link here in
case the mods haven't already best mods
in the world make sure you give them a
round of applause as we go but on Sunday
I haven't decided what time yet as we
get closer I'll announce it tomorrow or
I'll put it on social media or I'll put
it on the YouTube channel H and I'll
also put it on patreon if you want to
join in and join me on camera I'm gonna
have a signup sheet on Saturday on
Saturday I'll have a signup sheet on
patreon so you guys will be able to go
on and I will pick a handful of you the
first people that sign up on patreon uh
when I announce it you'll have the
ability to sign up I'll pick the first
handful of people and you will be able
to join me on camera uh as we do
kamakazi karaoke so I'll be singing
karaoke hell if you want to sing a
karaoke song you're more than welcome to
join in the reason why I'm doing it on
Twitch here's the reason why we did this
back in I think March or April on
YouTube uh the the the karaoke thing
well I I I use I'm not going to lie I
use YouTube karaoke videos to do the
karaoke right and so the problem is is
when I play the YouTube video and I
stream it on YouTube they shut it off so
you can't see it like it shuts off and
then it comes back on when the song's
off so I'm going to do it on Twitch [__]
them we'll just we'll do a workaround
the hell with
them we'll just do a workaround so
you're gonna be able to you're gonna be
able to go to Twitch so you're going to
want to follow uh twitch so make sure if
you want to participate this weekend and
everyone's going to be able to to
see everyone's going to be able to see
the karaoke right so just go to
twitch.tv thony Michels that's twitch.tv
Theon Michels or you can go to Theon
michaels.com scroll down and you can
join the twitch channel right that's
where you're going to want to be is on
the twitch Channel that's important or
you just go to twitch.tv and and search
the Tony Michaels you'll find the
channel follow the channel it is free to
follow on Twitch now if you have an
Amazon Prime account you can link the
Prime account to your Twitch account
because with prime you get one free uh
subscription to Twitch with Amazon
gaming I know it's kind of weird but
Amazon owns twitch is what happens and
they give you one free subscription to
Twitch so it's commercial free and it
gives us support because Amazon gives
twitch money and then twitch gives me a
couple cents like literally it's like
two bucks out of five is what I get when
you do it but it doesn't cost you a
single extra dollar if you're a prime
member and you will be able to watch the
karaoke this weekend on Sunday now the
patreon the patreon members you guys are
going to get a chance to sign up you're
G to get a chance to sign up to to join
me on camera you can ask me questions
we'll talk to each other and the whole
world will see on Twitch uh so make sure
you're watching that if you're patreon
member and if you want to be a patreon
member again go to the2 michaels.com you
can go down scroll down to memberships
support Tony on patreon is right there
patreon's kind of changing a bit too
it's it's changing um and they just
changed it like a week ago and I'm still
trying to get time to change the patreon
page so you're going to see some changes
over there one of the changes is is that
you're going to be able to go follow
patreon for free so you're going to be
able to follow me on patreon for free
you don't actually have to pay to follow
me on patreon which will be important
because what I'm going to start doing is
start making announcements over there
too um we've got the Discord we got
patreon there's just so many social
media channels honestly that when I post
I gotta post to like 15 of them so I so
I really I really would appreciate if
when it when it starts and I'll let you
guys know when it starts if you'll go
follow me on patreon it won't cost you a
single dollar to follow me um you might
have to download the app that'll be the
easiest way to follow it and their new
app is actually better than their old
app their old app sucked I'm not gonna
lie patreon's old app was [__]
garbage but the new one is getting
better it's not exactly what I would
want but it's getting better that's the
good news they're getting better and
better better um so so I'm I'm kind of
excited about the patreon I'm excited
about connecting with you guys over
there and I'm I'm excited at the
opportunity that you guys are going to
be able to follow me over there and kind
of see what's going on without having to
pay the $5 do $10 $20 and be a member um
now the members that pay in the certain
tiers will get access to certain to
certain stuff but really honestly we're
all over there we're all a family and I
know that most people in the higher
tiers are there to support me and
support the show and support the [__]
fam support our movement here as it were
with the pro-democracy Coalition with
the [__] fam you know right out front
you know punching Nazis and [__] you
know what I mean you know what I mean
we're not we we don't we don't beat
around the [__] Bush here and really
that's what pisses manga off more than
anything about us you know what I mean
the [__] fam they [__] hate us and
the reason why they hate us is because
we will We
Will We won't hold back we won't hold
back so I want you to not hold back I
want you to join me on patreon as soon
as it's free and if you consider to be a
member I want you to do that too uh
rather it's five 10 $20 of the higher
tiers I appreciate all the support all
the shots all the venmo super chats you
guys are the best audience in the world
I could not keep this microphone on
without you you are the
shareholders I am funded by you and that
is why I do not [__] just I I can't
say you can't say that Tony you can't
say this oh my God because we're totally
independent here
and you you breed that independence with
your support and it's not just monetary
support I want to point that out it's
also coming here every day and and and
listening to the show going to the
Discord and engaging on the Discord
engaging on social media not just with
me but with with the world uh spreading
around those great memes that I come up
with and the ones that I find and I kind
of give you guys the the ones I like the
best go spread those around a bit spread
the messaging and the narrative around
and really just dcent that's the main
thing descent is good um you know we've
had people push back on me and I I push
back a little more just because descent
is good in democracy that's what we need
uh in this country and in this world
more and more and more so I appreciate
every single last one of you no matter
what your no matter what your type of
Engagement no matter what how you want
to support the podcast here I appreciate
all of it even you maglites out there
even you little [__] traitors out
there that come here and hate watch this
thing I know there's a lot of people
that love me but there's probably just
as many or more that love to hate me and
if you love to hate me stick around
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
podcast
letters from the trucker
Convoy there's Tammy by the time we
reached DC we was 50 strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way we got plenty of slim gems
skull near run out Natty light hope it
don't rain tomorrow so we can Circle the
city again yours
Bob dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the LI love and blue one in your
absence I discovered a rash on my neck
and no it ain't no hickey and I even
seen my cousin Brody in
ages stay strong wipe your ass at least
once a day yours Tam
me [__] them [__] them [__] them [__]
them [__] them welcome we're back to the
Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast
welcome back to the
show the Tony Michaels podcast every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9th Pacific on
YouTube Facebook
and the twitch the twitcher whatever the
twitch
is Susan Susan on Facebook says Tony
loves maggots who love to hate watch I
absolutely 100% [__] do I love
getting underneath nazzi skin oh my God
it is it is one of my favorite things
ever I like getting under Nazi skin more
than I like singing karaoke way more
than I like Dr drinking Jagermeister and
you know how much I like singing karaoke
and drinking Jagermeister holy [__] but
getting under Nazi
skin oh man it should be an American
Pastime from now until the end of time
it really should be so I'm all here for
it and that's right I I I welcome I
welcome [__] [__] eaters to come
watch this show most most lefties or
most liberals or most the people who
have the shows on the left will block
every single person who will come and be
like Trump 2024 or some [__] like that
right they'll block them
or they'll get rid of them not me not
our mods our mods know I mean if you get
out of step and you're [__] attacking
people in the chat yeah get the [__] out
of here this is the chat isn't a
democracy for
sure but here's the thing if you come
here and you act you know accordingly
and you you know you don't get out of
hand and say stupid [__] to people
racist [__] you don't get crazy yeah you
come hate watch I love you love to hate
me I you know there's lefties that come
and hate watch too oh [__] there's
people on left [__] hate my guts that
I refer to myself as the rushing ball of
the left that I embrace that that
moniker that has been given to me by the
internet that pisses them off oh my God
they don't know what to do with it most
of the time they're like oh man that's
oh what does that mean what does that
mean well it means that we're not going
to stand back and let these idiots take
over our country that we'll do what they
did to our country if that's what we
have to do and we'll do it with the
goddamn truth instead of
Lies there ain't no reason that we can't
propagate the
truth sometimes though it is difficult
it I'm I'm not gonna lie it is it's a
[__] to propagate the truth [__]
lies you know the old adage that lies
will make it around the world twice
before the truth gets out of bed and
puts a shoes on that's that that's kind
of the truth Pro propaganda with lies is
so [__] easy because you don't have
to have any kind of backing you don't
have to have any kind of uh uh facts you
know those pesky little facts but you
know if you do it in a way if you
deliver the truth in a way that isn't
coupled or has to be coupled with data
and facts and you don't have to be the
smartest person on earth oh look look I
went to Harvard and there's this study
at Harvard and this poll shows and this
data proves [__] out of here we don't
need your goddamn data to prove what we
know is true okay these are simple these
are simple facts and simple basis of
truth that doesn't need a bunch of
goddamn
encyclopedias to get you in the right in
the right mindset okay it is not it is
not hard to understand that Americans
don't want to go broke because of a
medical bill got it
it is not hard for to understand and
know that this is a fact that almost
every single American 99.9% of Americans
do not want to go broke because of a
medical bill just go ask them go out
there and [__] ask them ask Democrats
ask Independents ask people who don't
know a goddamn thing about politics go
ask Maga supporters do you want to go
broke because of a medical bill who's
going to say yes to that huh who's going
to say yes to who you want to go broke
because of a medical bill what about
this one Americans want a decent [__]
wage huh that's pretty [__] easy
right that's a pretty easy argument
that's a pretty easy fact to have a
foundation on when you have an ideology
right when you have political
beliefs that's an easy one just go ask
anyone Democrats Independents people who
watch tyd people who watch o and Newsmax
just ask them do you think Americans
should have a decent [__]
wage I guarantee you're going to get a
lot of them that are gonna yeah you
[__] ain't right you goddamn right
you got damn right it's not it's not
complicated it really isn't complicated
stuff that's what Republicans did for 30
40 years and rushin ball was the [__]
head of the goddamn
snake in that effort to delude Americans
to believe crazy ass [__] that just
ain't even real like they believe that
Donald Trump has massive support in this
country what the [__] are you talking
about this guy is standing on stage this
weekend attacking BB Netanyahu and and
and praising Hezbollah really you think
this guy's got massive support are you
[__] kidding
me get the hell out of here with that
nonsense no one act there there are not
that many people that
believe that Joe Biden isn't going to
[__] just trounce Donald Trump in the
next election it's going to happen folks
I know a lot of people like Tony you
can't say that because that'll get
people's oh man they'll just no I'm
telling you discouragement breeds
disengagement that's what breeds
disengagement in
democracy is
discouragement not not [__] fighting
not ready to [__] beat your opponent
when you get fired up you know you got
the let's say you go to like a boxing
match right you've seen boxing matches
or just any sporting event footb
football game basketball game they got
the [__] fireworks going they got the
music we're going to beat their ass
we're the home team right they're doing
the cheers and the crowds
cheering and they're getting the crowd
involved with the Megatron you know what
I'm talking about and that baseball
games Take Me Out to the Ball Game take
me out to you know that song you know
that that's American Pastime that's what
breeds and G
M discouragement breeds disengagement
you see do you see how it works do you
see how human psychology work oh my God
it's a [__] oh my God holy [__] Tony are
you talking about humans communicating
with humans oh my
God you cannot you cannot breed
disengagement with discouragement you
can't do it you shouldn't do it
especially with a
lie when you when you try like with the
media's trying right now they're trying
to make this a close race so they make a
lot of money and to be honest with you
tyt and a bunch of these leftists and a
bunch of the media media uh Talking
Heads trying to [__] convince you
that oh my God there's a danger here
that Joe Biden could lose that's not the
danger the danger isn't that Joe Biden
could lose the danger is that [__]
these fascist can take over your
governments how the [__] don't you know
that how the hell don't you know that
that the Spear of the head of your
messaging should be
that that the discouragement that Joe
Biden could lose when that's a [__]
lie breeds
disengagement you stupid bastards they
don't know how it works the media the
leftwing don't know how it works and
that's why I embrace the moniker the
russling ball the left because guess
what as evil and as vile as that
[__] was he knew that point and
he used it he used his talent for vile
evil [__]
things he's one of the reasons why we'
slow slow roll to Maga to American Nazis
to American fascism trumpism in this
country and by God if we have to we can
undo it that way
too and if you don't think that we can
then fine whatever stand back hide and
watch I don't care I don't give a [__]
if you think the [__] them guy gives a
[__] what you're go what oh man well
what what the Talking Heads think or
what the corporate media
wants that's right I'll Attack the
corporate media corporate
media it's them trying to manipulate the
situation they think they have a huge
microphone and that they can manipulate
the situation they think they can scare
you scare you the way that they want to
scare you which is all [__]
[__] it's all [__] they're
selling lies like Fox News and MAA sells
lies and it's not it's not a good
situation when you discourage a
population because then they'll
disengage in their government especially
when you have a constitutional republic
like our democracy is that's a really
dangerous [__] aspect because then we
get a situation like
2016 where people disengage in the
[__]
process because of
discouragement oh Hillary's just as bad
as Trump you remember that [__] oh my
God her [__] emails emails emails
emails you remember that [__] you don't
think that that bred
discouragement you don't think the whole
Bernie bus movement didn't breed
discouragement and I'm not talking about
card holding Democrats or card holding
leftist I'm talking about in the country
as a whole
folks our democracy depends on
engagement just look at what we have
right now the [__] situation we
have if we could get if we could really
get people to
believe in red States and engagement
they wouldn't be that [__] red I I
hate to break it to you Texas isn't that
[__] red just like Georgia isn't that
[__] red everyone thought oh my God
Georgia is a red State 100% red state
they're not exactly red States what they
are what they are here's what they are
here's what they
are they are States where people are
discouraged so they disengage in their
democracy in that state and that is why
you get the results that you get in
those States it's not complicated stuff
it's just
not it's very important it's very
important it's very important that you
don't breed
disengagement and they do it all day
every day on MSNBC on CNN on other
networks tyt and others David
Pacman
yes David Pacman breeds
disengagement he does it with his
narrative it sucks he's bad at this I
mean he's good he's good at making
videos that get a lot of views there's a
lot of left there's a lot of people on
the left I'll admit there's a lot of
people on the left that are really good
and making YouTube videos that get a lot
of views oh that's
fantastic man that 62nd view got two
million views woohoo we made $5,000 off
that video well who gives a
[__] who gives a [__] if it bread
disengagement what the [__] the point
ju so you're saying a video that breeds
disengagement you're excited that it got
2 million views that's not exciting to
me that's not exciting to
me not at
all that's bad that's really [__] bad
and I'm not saying David Pacman should
stop doing what he's doing he should
just get better at it that's all I'm
saying he should get better at it and
understand what he's doing he should
understand what he's doing and if he
doesn't understand what he's doing he
should go look to he should go look to
rightwing talk and how successful
they've been at at [__] deluding
people making people believe outright
lies making people believe fascism is
what they want like this [__] [__]
on Facebook Shaz we're voting
DeSantis Shaz I had to tell you
dude like you're like the only
[__] that's going to be voting
for Des santis he's not going to win in
Iowa he's not going to win in New
Hampshire he probably won't even win the
straw he probably won't even get fifth
in the straw pole dude he's [__] he's
completely
[__] his political career is
over there's no path for him because
he's a [__] weirdo like you you're a
[__] weirdo man get with it but don't
go anywhere stay here stay here and keep
putting dumb [__] in the comments like
this we're we are voting DeSantis see
this isn't [__] Shaz isn't being vile
he isn't being an [__] so I haven't
[__] got rid of him yet I haven't
kicked him to the curb yet I haven't
shown him to the door and opened it with
his head yet on Facebook you know
hypothetically speaking and the reason
why is because Shaz is in the comments
saying really stupid stuff I don't know
I don't know if he's being paid by the
the Santos campaign to come here and say
this [__] because why else would someone
say this type of [__] in a chat
somewhere on a show like mine are you
serious why else would they if if it's
not deployed by the disantis campaign to
convince a bunch of people that the STIs
is going to win
anything you know what hey Shaz here's
what you should do go back to the santis
campaign I know you probably got their
number or an email or something I don't
know who you're communicating with over
there but here's what you should do
here's what you do go tell him that he
should run for speaker of the house go
do that oh man that'd be [__] great
wouldn't it imagine imagine if Ronda
santz ran for speaker of the house oh
[__] you talk about really ruining his
career imagine if he dropped that of can
you imagine that oh my God and I'm not
saying it's out of the realm of
possibility here who knows who's going
to be speaker of the house they can't
[__] decide who it
is I mean Democrats know who they want
to be speaker clearly and he will be the
speaker come January 2025 Hakeem Jeff
will be the speaker of the house and it
will be on the first ballot and there
won't be one [__] Democrat that will
vote but anything but Hakeem Jeff and
that's because they know how to govern
they know who their leader is they know
who they want to be their leader they
understand how governance Works they
understand how caucuses work they get it
right it's it's how a constitutional
republic actually
works especially when you have a
two-party democracy like our
constitutional republic
is but the right doesn't like democracy
they don't want it they actually don't
like the constitutional republic because
it affords you rights it affords you
Liberties so you get say in it and they
definitely don't want that because when
you get say in your democracy in your
country and your Liberty and your
freedoms and your rights and your
constitutional republic what happens is
is you're like yeah gate people can get
married what the [__] wrong with that
what does that have to do with me I
don't want someone telling me who I
can't get marri why the [__] would I
want to tell them who they can get
marry oh oh this person wants to use
certain pronouns okay on their social
media all right what the [__] does that
have to do with me it has not a goddamn
thing to do with me what the hell does
someone else's genitalia in a bathroom
have to [__] do with me I don't want
anyone else respecting my genitalia when
I go in the bathroom why in the [__] are
they talking about
it that's what happens is Americans and
people who believe in I don't know U uh
what's it called Freedom
Liberty they're like well if you take it
away from them then are you're gonna
take it away from me then I don't want
you to take my [__] away from me you
know they tried that [__] in 1930s
Germany you know that right and Italy
they tried that [__] they took they were
they [__] they murdered six six
million Jewish
people so that way they could take away
people's rights murdered murdered even
more Germans French because they
wouldn't bend a knee and capitulate to
the Nazis really okay yeah I I don't
think we want to do that [__] again
that's kind of not a thing that we
really like to do because you know
ignoring what the Germans did is
what we're not going to do we're not
going to ignore it because ignoring it
is what caused that [__] right that's
why they don't want democracy that's why
people like Shaz will say [__] like oh
we're not a democracy we're a
constitutional
[Applause]
republic because they given up on
Democracy they given up on politics in
general that's really the rub here
that's why you got that [__] [__]
down in Tennessee and Franklin having
not protector trying to be a mayor
candidate you think you think Gabriel
Hansen that Nazi is going to try to is
going to stop it being mayor she's an
alderman now and then she's gonna be a
mayor you don't think she's gonna try to
seek a state state house seat or a state
senate seat or then a congressional seat
in United States Congress you don't
think so come on now that's how that
[__] starts where do you think these
[__] Congress people come from where
do you think [__] state
representatives and state senators and
Governors come from they come from being
aldermen being
Mayors that's why I'm trying to [__]
tell you over and over and over again
hey they're [__] Nazis look hello hey
come here look hey look here look here
Nazis Nazis Nazis it's it's not because
I have some kind of derangement syndrome
it's because I'm seeing what's happening
I watched history I I I looked at it
it's really not hard to study
authoritarian governments and
authoritarian dictators and
authoritarian movements like the Nazi
German German movement in the
1930s and 40s up until that [__]
coward put a gun in his
mouth because that's really how fascism
ends for fascist a lot of
times it's How It Ends for them and the
reason why is because of us
us because we say wait a second wa wait
wait wait wait wait you're saying that
people in Tennessee can't dress up as
women and get on stage and do a
performance because you it makes you
feel
uncomfortable because it makes you get
all kind of weird feeling inside what
the [__] what are you gonna tell me what
the [__] I can and can't wear then what
about me you're G to take it away from
them you take it away from
me that's what they're scared of that's
what they're terrified
of [__] terrified of
it and they've commenced the popul
through right-wing talk
radio FOX News o Newsmax the right-wing
Talking Heads like Benny Johnson Seb
Gorka these [__] just vile pieces of
Nazi trash
Trump and all his [__] allies Mike
Flynn his son his dumbass son Eric and
Donnie Jr booger sugar
Jr these [__] just Nazi
scumbags and they continue Mark Mark
lvin Sean Hannity Glenn Beck godamn I
could go on for [__] days and that's
not even including the local radio
stations and the local TV networks and
then the [__] edbd [__] YouTube
channels that pump this garbage into
people's brains I've showed you that
[__] crazy loon what's her name the
the the the the [__] that gets emails
from God you know what I'm talking about
that that [__] vile piece of [__]
her you think she had a huge following
nope you think she still has a huge
following probably not that big just big
enough to spread her nonsense spread her
[__] that's how it works
folks and they
honestly W when they do it they're doing
propaganda really good
unfortunately the rightwing in this
country really has [__] honed
right-wing Li lion Nai propaganda down
to a [__]
science and rush them ball was the start
of all of
that so what are we going to do we going
to stand back and just let them keep
doing that and just go well there's
nothing we can do about it oh godamn
there's nothing we can do about it
man maybe they're right maybe it's
really not a democracy maybe it is a
constitutional republic because that's
what they want to convince you
they want to convince you that you don't
have a democracy that way when your
democracy is taken from you you don't
think you lost
anything that's the whole [__]
purpose of the propaganda in the first
place that's why Shaz comes here and
talks about how the whole country is
gonna vote for the santis this guy's
[__]
delusional just [__] delusional Oh
see now he's begging please
please vote for D sandis and lock up
transgenders Chez what's your PornHub
history look
like what does it look like
man I'm sure it's mired with the people
that you're saying to lock up are you
scared are you scared are you scared oh
you're frightened oh my God oh my God
why are you so focused on someone's
genitalia dude and why do you think a
politician why do you think that one
[__] that one
[__] in this country is going to
do what you want you understand what
that what that is right chz do you get
it do you get that when you say the only
the only thing that matters is
to lock up your fellow countrymen
because of who they are and the only
person that's going to do that is
DeSantis you know what that is that's
called
fascism he's Hitler dummy you're the
Nazis hey you're the baddy you [__]
idiot that's what that [__]
means so keep watching man eventually
maybe some of this [__] will leak into
your brain and what brain cells you got
left to rub together it'll start to
[__] make
sense and this is why I do the show I do
the show I do the show because there is
there is a sense of what we can do for
people who have been [__]
deluded deluded by lies and
hate do I get angry if you [__] ain't
right do I get pissed off you you
goddamn right I'm gonna be pissed is it
a righteous type of anger I guess is it
cathartic you damn straight it probably
is and and am I going to run away from
the moniker the rustling ball the left
when it works nope not going to do it
and if you don't like it I don't give a
[__] I don't give a [__] I don't give a
[__] if you don't like it I don't care
I'm gonna [__] lean into it and the
reason why is I'm gonna lean into it is
because it makes
sense it makes sense to me it makes
sense to you it should make sense to the
country and I'm telling you as our
audiences get bigger and bigger and
bigger and they listen to me talk and
especially when they when when I talk
against the people who are damaging our
country when they think they're trying
to help our democracy because they're
doing it wrong they've been told and
taught and they believe what they
believe but it's wrong it's wrong the
way you're doing your content you
[__] idiots some of you out there
it's wrong it's not working it's the
opposite discouragement breeds
disengagement that's what it [__]
does you have to encourage people you
have to get people excited about
democracy you have to get people excited
about their role in
democracy in in the battlefield of the
ballot you have to get them [__]
excited about it not discouraged if they
get discouraged they don't want anything
to do with it why do you think the
majority of Americans don't want
anything to do with politics is because
the media in this country and the left
in this country has continued to
discourage
them continued every [__] day what
Tony what's the difference than what you
do I point out the actual
threat to your democracy I show it to
you I'm like here's a threat here's why
it's threat here's why you should be
pissed go be pissed and go get engaged
and use that [__] anger and that
righteous anger and that [__]
cathartic release and that strategic
outrage to prop up
democracy to stand on liberal Democratic
principles so that our our constit
tional Republic will be around tomorrow
and next year and the next election and
the next [__]
Century that's it it's pretty [__]
simple it's not complicated at all it
really isn't and these [__] idiots
want to make it complicated because
they're like well to get to get clicks
on YouTube here's what you got to do
here's what you got to do to get views
on YouTube oh to build to build your
YouTube channel you got to do this
because that that'll definitely and and
here's the thing is you don't want to
piss off righties because the manga will
come and they'll troll your F your
YouTube p and you just have to block
them and block them and block them do
you know how many do do you know how
many people I block on my YouTube
page not that many not that
many not that many I don't block
actually any of them I leave it up to
the moderators because we have the best
moderators in the [__] world here at
the Tony Michaels podcast period I want
to give you a sense um last month we had
314 or over over almost
35,000 total views here on this channel
and I'm not monetized so I don't get
into the
algorithm there is sometimes there's
damn near 2,000 people that watch this
live YouTube twitch and
Facebook on three different
platforms we had 6 million minutes
watched on YouTube
last month alone that's the stat YouTube
sent it to me this
morning 6 million minutes watched now
it's not a lot compared to some some get
six million views a day six million
views a week and I'm getting six million
minutes watched a month oh but it's G to
get bigger it's going to get bigger and
the reason why is because this this is
the show that everyone wants and needs
they don't want the [__] algorithm to
tell them what to listen to they they're
tired of people making [__] content
based on the algorithm of what the
algorithm wants them to
have honestly they're sick and tired of
of lose feel like they're losing grip of
their democracy because content creators
want to make 60-second viral videos that
don't do a [__] thing for democracy
not a goddamn
thing and you guys encourage every
[__] day you guys leave comments
every day that says Don't Stop Don't
Stop Don't Stop Don't Stop Don't
Stop and I believe if I come here every
day for two hours and pound the drum and
just Beat It To Death that pound it and
pound it and pound it and pound it and I
repeat the same things over and over and
over and over again give you the truth
every day day after day after day after
day and more people that come watch this
they'll
know they'll know that the other content
is [__] [__] it doesn't it doesn't
help democracy it's not it's not
helping some of it is breeding
disengagement even though it's getting
millions of views which is not a good
thing it's
not we'll get millions of views every
[__] day every day we'll get it I
hope this chat is so goddamn [__]
large that it almost shuts down because
of how many live viewers we have every
day I think we're going to get
there people are talking in the in the
chat about the shorts on YouTube you
know what I love about the shorts the
best I I said this the other day and and
skip over on Discord he he helps he
helps cut those clips he produces those
clips for us at the Tony Michaels
podcast so thank you skip for your your
work we got a lot of them coming here
soon are going to pile up but here's the
thing here's the best part about them so
like we'll we'll release a clip right
and it kind the algorithm like feeds it
like to the to the audience you know to
the followers a little bit not all of
them but like a little bit feed it to it
you know what I mean and then like two
days go by and YouTube's like you know
what we should show this to we should
show this to the maggots we should show
this to the maglites the right-wingers
on YouTube see what they think and oh my
God when they when they inject when they
inject my type of [__] commentary for
the
left into manga's bubble they [__]
lose their minds they're like this guy's
from California what are you a libtard
what do you you drink soy milk all kinds
of [__] just just [__] ridiculous
ass comments they're like Trump
2024 oh like shabs go vote for the STIs
oh he's a great fascist we love Hitler
that sort of [__] you know what I mean
they're like yeah we're not a democracy
we're Republic that sort of [__] oh they
I [__] love it I actually I actually
and to all the right Wingers out there
that may see this at some point I
actually love your comments the most oh
my God I love your [__] comments the
most because when you come in the
comments and you're mad at me because of
what I'm
saying it only and you're you're the one
saying it you're the one saying it it
only reassures me that I'm saying the
correct thing that I have the exact
right messaging that it's on [__]
point because you know what I was
telling you this the other day Texas
Paul said that I get death threats I
don't get a lot of death threats I don't
get a lot of them very rarely do I get a
death
threat do you know
why do you know why it's because my
commentary is different than anyone
else it's different it's not the same
it's
correct and I hate to Pat myself on the
back but you guys know this you're here
every day two hours what is it about the
show what is it about the show that
makes you come watch two hours it can't
be my my [__] ugly ass face is it the
beard is it the background is it the the
dick Shadow is it come on it's the
attitude it's the
tone [__] the very beginning is
like let's talk about
democracy you [__] eating
morons right the same [__] language
the same
language that they use do you know that
was my intent with the opening song
everyone loves the opening of this show
it's the best opening is what they say
this is the best opening of any [__]
podcast of any leftwing show out there
do you want to know why do you want to
know the secret I'll tell you because I
I modeled it after rightwing talk
radio because they know what they're
doing I know it sounds weird to say that
but they
know they
know and they're not scared to do
it they're not scared to do it they're
not scared to give you their [__] raw
truth right Wingers aren't scared of
being wrong they're not right wiers are
definitely not scared of being wrong
they're wrong a lot every day like all
[__] day long they just step on
reeks I'm not scared of being wrong I'm
not I'm not scared of being wrong if I'm
wrong I'm wrong yesterday I said Jim
Jordan is gonna be your speaker house
and then all of a sudden Steve scl is
gonna be the speaker of the house and
then 30 minutes later after I got off
the air Steve scales is not going to be
the speaker of the house I don't have a
crystal ball I mean it seems like it
sometimes because I just kind of you
know gauge what's reality and what's
not so that's the ticket that's what we
should be
doing and we should do it over and over
and over and over and over again and one
of these days I promise you one of these
days you're gonna be like who's this guy
over here who's coping Tony hey hey
here's another Tony copy hey look here's
another here's another show that's
copied Tony hey did you hear David
Pacman's being more like
Tony he's changing his narrative he's
changing his content good that's what I
want how do you think the rightwing
convince this country of just outright
lines like shz here that [__] [__]
on
Facebook how they convince these
[__] of these outright lies is
they pound the drum all day long and
they never [__]
stop and they don't give a [__] if
they're wrong if they're right they
don't give a [__] what they're trying to
do is set a
narrative and they're trying to drive
messaging and they don't they don't
[__] focus group at first and then
test it out here and then see if these
people like this messaging well who's
going to be offended by what this
messaging is who gives a good
godamn there's plenty of people on the
left that [__] [__] hate my
guts I'm sure there's prenty of tyt
loyalist that watch me that [__] hate
to hear what I say especially when I
talk against
them this whole Israel Hezbollah or
excuse me Israel Hamas keep saying
Hezbollah because Grandpa poopy pants
thinks it's great to support
Hezbollah what's he gonna endorse Isis
next I don't [__] know
but that's why it's it's such a
complicated issue because of the
religion and the humanitarian aspect of
it and commentators are so scared like
the you know commentators and I'll call
Texas Paul out a little bit on this
because the other day he was he was
equating Palestinians with Hamas which
is not real that's not a thing you
shouldn't do that because that's not
what you should do there are pity
Palestinians who are part of Hamas yes
that is true there are Americans who are
manga
right but just because a bunch of
[__] domestic terrorists in our
country who who are manga went to the
capital to try to overturn our
government and turn it over to Trump as
a dictator doesn't mean all Americans
are
manga you follow it do you see that you
see that through line there and that's
okay it's okay to be wrong it's okay to
be in this area that doesn't make a lot
of sense it's
okay but you don't have to do it the
wrong way you can do it the right way
you can do it the correct
way and that's what I want to do here
every single weekday two hours a day
pounding the
drum every time boom boom boom boom so
don't go anywhere when we come back
we're GNA watch we're gonna watch some
of this stuff right after this
break we'll be right back Mark 60
seconds this is the Tony Michaels
[Music]
podcast trying to remember all the
things you boycotted can really get you
stressed because there's no good way to
keep them from becoming a cluttered mess
well now there's boycott binder the
ingenious organizer that keeps track of
everything and everyone you've ever
boycotted the 72 category filing system
makes it easy to organize boycotted
people places and things so you can find
them with ease the large centered area
can even fit your boycott sign but best
of all when you're done the boycott
binder folds right up so you can take it
anywhere so if you're tired of having a
cluttered mess call now and get the
boycott binder for just
$29.99 plus you'll also receive our next
rep as a bonus just Loop it around your
neck to travel with ease but call right
now and we'll double the offer that's
two boycott binders and two neck straps
for just
$29.99 foyot binders brought to you by
the same makers of binders full of
women jumping back into it this is the
Tony Michaels
podcast welcome back to the show the
Tony Michaels podcast here on YouTube
Facebook and twitch every single Monday
through Friday new Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific every [__] for
two full hours every last one of them
Monday through Friday so I can show you
and give you a sense of what the hell is
going on oh my god did you see
everyone's talking about uh Jank in the
um he's running for president I I'll do
a little commentary on that first
because that's hilarious oh my
God I can't tell you how funny this
is are you serious you're going to run
pres okay so let's go over the
naturalized citizen thing first
apparently Jank is a is
a a naturalized citizen which you know
in in the world of Maga and maglites you
know when they were saying Obama
wouldn't born here blah blah BL he W
born here I mean I'm not saying that
naturalized citizens shouldn't have more
rights to participate in the government
I mean it's going to be a it's going to
be a thing where we have to decide
whether where rather we would let a
naturalized citizen be the president of
the United States because it's not
really it's not a thing yet right and we
haven't had a decision made on that yet
Ted Cruz Ted Cruz I'm talking I'm
talking to you Ted Cruz who wasn't um
born in this country he's born in Canada
I don't know if you know that about Ted
Cruz he ran for president he's running
for Senate oh my God even my dog hates
Ted Cruz did you know that I bet your
cat even hates Ted Cruz just [__]
hates his guts it might be because he
was born in Canada I doubt it it's
probably because he's a [__] and he's
just ruins Texas but know and he gives a
bad name to people from Texas to be
quite honest with you anyone that's from
Texas is probably [__] or needs to be
at least at a bare minimum ashamed that
their Senator is Ted Cruz but so you
know I I I have I think there's a a lot
of good debate that could come from a
naturalized citizen actually seeking the
presidency of the United States I'm not
going to lie that that point that point
there is actually a debate I think would
be good for the country now we we don't
need to do that debate now I hate to
tell you that democracy's on the line
here so having this big huge National
debate about oh can we have a
naturalized citizen be the president of
United States I don't think is really
something we need to sort out just like
we don't need to sort out whether
there's cameras in in a federal
courtroom or the stupid idea that you're
gonna 14th Trump with secretaries of
state that's some dumb [__] that just we
don't need to sort that out that's
stupid ass [__] that's a distraction
it's not a real thing it's it's not even
based in any kind of [__] reality I
know I know the 14th amendment in
section three says it so Glenn says it
so you want it to be true I get it I I
understand I I get it I I don't want
Trump to be [__] president either nor
do I want him to be on a ballot I wish
the [__] would have conceited
and slinked Away to Mar Lago and lived
his [__] the rest of his miserable
life and got out of our [__] lives
but that's not what happened that's not
the reality so here we are but but Jank
run for president man come on you
couldn't you could you couldn't even get
Maryann convinced a bunch of your
[__] leftist audience that Mar it was
a good idea to have Maryann Williamson
to be president of United States you
know that right that's how inept you are
that you couldn't even convince your
audience that she should be the
president what makes anyone believe that
you're gonna have any kind of support
what what are you gonna go you're gonna
run on JF or RFK Jr's ticket I say JFK
Jr a lot because I don't know maybe I
believe he's still alive too to some
degree you know like I mean they've kind
of gaslighted me enough that like maybe
[__] who knows maybe he'll reincarnate
in Dallas somewhere I don't know [__] I
don't know I don't know how it works but
is Jen gonna go run on rfk's ticket you
think do you think they'll like run on
the same ticket be like a Unity ticket
oh there you go hey no labels there you
go Ain No Labels hey you [__] there
you go you get RFK Jr he's a former
Democrat since you don't want Trump to
win that's the lie that you tell
everyone he's a for and you got Joe
mansion in your in your court RFK Jr's
sort of a sort of a kind of a used to be
a he's not really but he's just an idiot
but he said he was a Democrat at one
point the the old tyt dummy over there
oh man you could really get them you
could get them on a Unity ticket and
that would be no labels right I mean
hell that that might work go for it that
sounds like a really that's that sounds
s like a really stiff winner right there
doesn't
it oh my God you know it's [__] weird
is that we are in a timeline where that
actually could be a thing on the
internet in the next 60 days I'm not
[__] you we are in a Time crazy ass
timeline right now we live in a wild
[__] time it is a wild time to be
alive folks it's a c on world we're just
living in it that in the next 60 days
RFK and and the tyt idiot could end up
on a Unity ticket
together I mean is it out of the realm
of possibility here
really I mean is it uh someone's
pointing out here on Facebook that Jank
that Jank off I like to call him Jank
I'm not really sure how to pronounce it
because some people say sank but I don't
think it's
sank I mean it looks like shank but I
like shank because I'm a hillbilly and
sounds like he's you know janking
it uh so I'll call him whatever I want
to call him um but here's the thing is
they're pointing out if I can find the
comment the chat goes so [__] fast
because you guys are so engaged um but
the comment uh here was that um um that
Jen ran for congress in
La uh some time ago and he got like six%
of the
vote
whoosh whoosh that's rough I I wonder
how much I wonder how much much of the I
wonder how much of the country is just
dying to have him oh boy I wonder how
much he dying to have him and again
people are pointing out the point the
fact that he was born in a different
country which again I'm not saying we
shouldn't have that
debate I don't I'm not saying because I
mean Ted Cruz was trying to run for
president he was born in [__] Canada
you know that right he was born in
Canada we kind of did this debate with
John McCain John McCain was not born in
the United States in the 50 states he
was was born on a naval base and they
sorted that out and said yeah he's on a
naval base it's technically American
soil so yeah he's a natur he's a he's a
citizen he's a natural born citizen so I
I'm not saying we shouldn't have that
debate about naturalization and how much
you know they should participate because
honestly I'm I'm I'm
actually of the notion that we should
let anyone who's anyone in this country
vote especially in local elections like
their school boards their City councils
their their Road
districts did you know that there's
people who are not citizens of this
country who live they own property they
live in in a certain area they send
their kids to school they pay taxes to
the school to the library to the fire
department they they pay taxes to the
city they pay sales tax when they go buy
groceries or go to the store in those
towns in those communities and they
don't have any say over it whatsoever
does that sound like a [__] Republic
to you does that sound like a democracy
to you just because just because they
weren't born here they came here to
participate in our country you think
that they don't have the right to vote
for who runs their road
district really that's what you're
[__] worried about you're worried
about people in communities oh they're
not a citizen of this country so they
shouldn't have the right to have the say
over the roads in their Community even
though they own property they own
businesses they work there they live
there their families [__] live there
they shop there they they they volunteer
there they com they participate in the
communities there they shouldn't have
say over the roads or the schools come
on man you're [__] ignorant that's
ignorant as [__] so yeah there's a
there's a decent debate but I I'm I'm
gonna tell you that that debate isn't
with this [__]
idiot it's not tyt that the tyt idiot is
not the one that you want to have this
debate not in this moment in time
shank is what someone say that stank so
is it stank is it sank is it Jank how do
you say his name I don't know some
people be like oh Tony you're a bastard
you're making fun of his name I don't
know how to say his name I mean I could
say it like it spelled like American
would say it I mean in the state of
Missouri we don't wash
our clothes we worsh them there's a
[__] R in there apparently there's
people around the the city of St Louis
that don't [__] on the toilet they [__]
on the toilet there's an r in there
trilet it's a toilet you [__] on the
trilet I don't to tell you about this in
in Missouri there's a town called Neva
nadaa Missouri did you know that you go
down to Nevada and seriously when you go
there if you call it Nevada they will
[__] eat your lunch you're like it
ain't Nevada that's a goddamn State on
the other side of the country okay it's
Nevada I'm dead serious just [__]
drive to Nevada Missouri and then go in
like a store and say Nevada that you're
in Nevada oh my God it's not gonna go
well for you just
saying you know you get me all pissed
off if you
want pronounced Jank Jen [__] Jen I like
Jank because he's janking off you know
what I
mean because that's mostly what doing on
air most of the time he's just doing the
old circle jerk he's not really giving
people the real raw truth he's just
lying to them he's trying to get him to
buy his products like Alex Jones does
you know some people call me the Alex
Jones of the left they've said that
which that's not very that's not very
accurate because I don't H Hawk boner
pills on my website and Hawk some sort
of health supplement that's made me so
strong he gave me muscles I mean that's
what T does you know that right you know
that right that's what tyt does tyt
Hawks their own
products so that that that that their
supporters will buy them and then they
feed them full [__] to keep them
watching so they can keep Hawking them
the the [__] whatever the health
supplement or whatever the hell it is
that they're
Hawking it happens what are you gonna do
okay do you get the point about Jen
gunger you know who gives a [__] I mean
that's who gives a
[__] you know what we should be worried
about you know we should be worried
about I don't know if you know this who
we should be worried about is the guy
who used to be the president of the
United States who the Republicans are
going to nominate because they they
[__] suckle at the orange teeth of
stupidity and he's on stage yesterday
praising hisbah I'm not [__] [__]
you you're my favorite turd I wouldn't
[__] you listen to this idiot listen to
this [__] [__] and they said gee I
hope Hezbollah doesn't attack from the
north because that's the most vulnerable
spot I said wait a minute you know
Hezbollah is very smart they're over
what hezbollah's what what did he say
you know like vile terrorist comes to
mind pieces of [__] trash those kinds
of words might be but he has the best
words so what did he call him with the
best words let's listen again you know
hezel is very smart they're all very
smart the Press doesn't like when they
say it yeah they don't the Press doesn't
like when you say that because it makes
it look like you're in favor of
Hezbollah are you [__] [__] me do
you know the history of Hezbollah hezb
like 30 years ago [__] murdered
murdered United States Marines they're a
terrorist organization just like Hamas
is a terrorist organization just like
Isis is a terrorist organization just
like Al-Qaeda y Qaeda here in this
country as they're called the Taliban oh
do you know do you know who else this
[__] loves speaking of Taliban
this [__] loves
Taliban him and his secretary of state
wanted to [__] meet with him at Camp
David in this
country on September
11th do you remember that oh but get mad
at Tony when Tony tweets that Maga is
American Hamas you people are stupid if
you think I'm at a turn because I'm
saying MAA is American
Hamas you're not paying
attention is what you're not
doing so if you get mad and upset that I
call MAA American Hamas because that's
what the [__] they are look listen let
me let me back it up take a listen again
and they said gee I hope Hezbollah
doesn't attack from the north because
that's the most vulnerable spot I said
wait a minute you know hezb is very
smart they're all very smart the Press
doesn't like when they say you know they
don't like it again it's because you're
the one who want to negotiate with
Taliban you wanted toite terrorists and
negotiate with terrorists at Camp David
on September 11th you gross
[__] you again folks we gotta
Get
Right ignoring it is what the Germans
did okay okay ignoring that they're
terrorist ignoring that they're fascist
is where the Germans went wrong they
just ignored it they didn't push back
they didn't punch like they should have
been punching back politically and and
with roric like a [__] this guy
is a goddamn cult leader he's a goddamn
leader of a terrorist organization MAA
their domestic
terrorist period
period he again I don't I don't know
what else I can how I can say it I'm
gonna show you where he attacks Benjamin
Netanyahu which I tell you what I got a
lot of disagreements with BB oh [__]
that guy's just a fascist himself isn't
he BB Netanyahu oh and that's really
unpopular to say right now in this
moment to to speak out against BB
Netanyahu but he is BB Netanyahu is a
fascist [__] and and he's really
he's he's really probably not the best
leader for Israel now there's one thing
about BB Netanyahu that that Israelis
like is the guy fully understands the
complexity of the Middle East he
definitely does that's one thing that's
one point that BB Netanyahu does very
well is he understands the complexities
of the Middle East and that is why
Israelis put up with his ass
okay but in this moment where you're not
supposed to attack BB Netanyahu like I
just kind of went against him Trump
yesterday attacked BB Netanyahu not in a
way that I did not in the way that I
just like hey I don't really agree with
his politics right like I know Joe Biden
does not agree with BB netanyahu's
politics I know that that's 100%
Democrats don't agree with everything BB
Netanyahu in his politics he's kind of a
crook too he's got this I don't know
kind of a corrupt little stench to
him and that's the truth but also the
truth is is that he is the prime
minister of Israel who is our Ally who
just got [__] attacked by a terrorist
group Hamas and got thousands of their
citizens [__] murdered and killed so
I mean there's that too there's that
truth too so there's a couple different
truths that we trying to manage here
it's why it's very complex issue that's
why a lot of commentators are have a
hard time saying what they want to say
when they should just say what they want
to say instead of what is popular or
what people want to hear are telling
Their audience what Their audience wants
to hear the [__] are you talking about
why why are you why are you capitulating
just say the [__] truth would you bb
Netanyahu is not that great when you
look through the lens of his ideology
and his politics Jesus Christ he's doing
a lot of things in Israel that looks
like he's trying to undermine democracy
I'm not going to lie that's a thing
that's a
fact but also he's the prime minister of
Israel who just got attacked by a
terrorist organization
Hamas who has a lot of similarities with
I don't know other terrorist
organizations in the Middle East like
Hezbollah who's backed by Iranians which
if you want to know who backs Iran it's
Putin and that's where all this chaos I
believe is truly coming from it's
Putin I don't know other Teran ex oans
like Isis you remember them Isis you
remember how we wanted to eradicate Isis
because they were [__] murdering
people beheading people kidnapping
people you remember that I mean it's a
little different because Isis was really
looking for a caliphate that they didn't
exist because they were
refugees and the Palestinians aren't
exactly refugees because that's the
truth
too oh my
God not all Palestinians are
Hamas you know there's there's
Palestinians that live all over our
Globe all over the
Earth and a lot of them condemn Hamas
they're probably
ashamed of Hamas just like you might be
ashamed as an American of Maga and this
[__] right I mean how many
people in this chat are [__] ashamed
that this country has to put up with
this piece of trash and his [__]
manga cult following the domestic
terrorist that they are how many Are you
ashamed of that you don't think
Palestinians all around the world are
[__] ashamed of Hamas and what they
did and the tragedy now there's some
people that aren't speaking
out for whatever reason or the
next but these are the truths that we
have to deal with and to not say them to
not say them and to not Point them out
and to and to oh I can't tell my
audience that I don't believe that
there's anything I Can't Tell You Folks
not a [__] thing not one [__] and
I I think I've proven that
that there's not one thing I don't think
I can tell
you because I believe I believe that
every single one of you are capable of
hearing the [__] truth no matter how
uncomfortable it may
be and the people here who aren't able
to handle the uncomfortable truth I
believe I'm good enough to hold the
audience and get them coming back every
day that they they will start to get
comfortable with knowing the truth even
if it's not comfortable for them to know
at
first it's okay it's all right we we can
work through that I'm willing to sit
here and do that every single day just
keep going you see how that works I was
talking about it you know half hour ago
but let's continue with this [__]
idiot because I'm going to show you the
clip of him him talking about how he's a
crybaby and he doesn't like BB Netanyahu
and then I'm G to show you a couple
clips of why Maga is Hamas but I'm gonna
show you why this guy doesn't like BB
and Natan yahu and it's not because he
disagrees with him politically
or whatever it's because this guy this
guy is a [__] little [__] a whiny
little [__] [__] but let's watch
this no I said that President she of
China 1.4 billion people he controls it
with an iron fist I said he's a very
smart man they killed me the next day I
said he was smart whatever no they I
mean they're not really killing you
because you're saying G is smart you're
saying he rules with an iron fist it
makes us believe that that's what you
want to do you you [__] chucklehead
what a bonehead when you say that he
rules with an Iron Fist and it's so
smart that he does that it's like oh
that smells like fascism that smells
like you want to be a dictator come on
you don't see that [__] dummy oh
that's right you don't have enough
[__] brain cells Mr adderal here let
keep going I
GNA a National Defense Minister or
somebody I hope hezb doesn't attack us
from the north so what an idiot yes
they're saying that out loud because
they're trying to warn [__] all
around the world how don't how does he
was President for four [__] years and
he hasn't figured this [__] out holy
[__] Jesus
Christ aren't you happy that we got our
asses out and engaged in democracy in
2020 and elected and elected a guy that
is willing to get up in the morning put
his shoes on and do the job at least I
mean you may not agree with everything
that [__] does or how he does it
or how he says it but at least he
[__] does the job this guy did he was
there for four years and didn't even
understand what the job was clearly he
doesn't what a [__] idiot here's the
clip of him attacking attacking prime
minister Netanyahu and again he's not
packing him on political issues listen
to this sh we followed the
whole about 15 seconds later it was all
over and we did it but I'll never
forget I'll never forget that BB
Netanyahu let us down that was a very
terrible thing I will say that and do do
you see how excited the crowd is you
notice how excited his Crowds Are lately
when I show you Clips like yeah oh yeah
okay yeah that's great great when he's
talking about whales and windmills he's
like they're like yeah whales and what
what is he talking about windmills and
whales what the [__] is he saying they
just they have no do idea what the hell
he's talking about the reason why is
because Donald Trump's been told by his
lawyers hey if you do your old uh
standup comic routine that you've been
doing that all that material you have
you're probably G to be put in jail so
you might want to come up with a new
stick so he's working out new material
he's working out a new stick here um but
it's not going so well keep going there
Grandpa let's hear the story that you
got to tell us about BB Netanyahu and
why he let you down
so when I see sometimes the intelligence
you talk about the intelligence or you
talk about some of the things that went
wrong over the last week they've got it
straighten it out because they're
fighting potentially a very big Force
they're fighting potentially
Iran and when they have people saying
the wrong things everything they say is
being digested by these people because
they're vicious and this smart okay all
right I'm gonna stop here it's just a
bunch of [__] word salad really oh my
God and he dude take more Aderall please
this is boring as [__] like it used to
be like you'd have word sound and at
least it was [__] entertaining to
some degree you're getting [__]
boring man I mean you're you put me to
sleep more than [__] Ronda santis
does or Mike Pence can you imagine being
more boring than [__] Mike Pence holy
[__]
[__] think about that bar right like
here's the bar that Mike Pence is
[__] boring as a [__] saltin
cracker right and then here's
Trump right there what the f where's the
Charisma huh where's the energy where's
it at huh sleepy Dawn where is it man it
feels like you're gonna [__] fall
asleep up there in the middle of your
word salad but I want to point something
out here about what he's
saying and the thing the thing that he's
saying is about Iran do you remember
when he was the president of the United
States and he fired James Comey as the
Director of the FBI and immediately
immediately had
labro the Russian in the [__] Oval
Office with only Russian cameras right
they only let Russian equipment into the
wi house into the O office so that he
could have a little chuckle and rub
elbows with labro and laugh it up
about I fired Comey because he was
looking into that Russia
stuff now no one can come at me how how
how and lro's like hey why don't you
give us uh Intel secrets about Israel
why don't that way we can pass them
along to
Iran that way maybe when we give them
the money when Russians give the funding
to Iran to give the Hamas to attack
Israel that way I don't know maybe
they'll know their way around the Iron
Dome maybe they'll know like the you
know the secrets so let's hear them
Donnie let's he the secrets I don't know
if that
happened but it's a possibility how else
do you think how else do you think Hamas
figured out how to [__] get around
the Iron Dome I don't know I guess only
time will s and boy are they vicious cuz
nobody's ever seen the kind of sight
that we've seen nobody's ever seen it
but they cannot play games so we were
disappointed by that very disappointed
but we did the job ourselves it was
absolute Precision magnificent beautiful
job and then
uh BB tried to take that was that didn't
make me feel too good but that's all
right oh I'm such a crybaby oh Benjamin
Netanyahu the Israeli had nothing to do
with it and they tried to take credit
they did have something to do with it
you [__] bonehead what an idiot he
knows
this he knows this that Israelis had a
lot to do with it with killing solomani
yeah they had a lot to do with it Jesus
Christ he even said it in the speech and
BB Netanyahu actually gave Trump credit
I don't know if you I don't know if you
[__] if he knows that either but BB
Netanyahu is like thanks president Trump
for
killing
solomani what a [__] bonehead man and
anyone who supports this idiot just
[__] absolute
boneheads I can't even describe you how
[__] infuriating it is here's a good
one here's one I'll show you this I'm
not gonna show you this clip because I
really don't want to listen to this
[__] I'm just GNA read his his
tweet um it's DC D Dro Rogan Rogan this
guy is delusional as a [__] and
I've told him time and time and time and
time and time and time again that his
delusion is going to be Trump and
manga's downfall which is the [__]
truth doubt me on that their [__]
delusion is going to be their downfall
but I pointed out this morning here's
how I'm pointing it out here's your
daily reminder that MAA is America's
Hamas um here you go here's the [__]
tweet I was invited to speak on a panel
before President Trump's rally for club
47 in West Palm Beach yesterday oh well
just [__] exciting
Rogan the moderator asked my favorite
memory of trump and you know what what I
said what did you say man well we could
only guess what a terrorist would say oh
that's right you love the terrorist
attack that you committed on our Capital
to overthrow our vote and our government
yeah we we [__]
know oh man oh man some [__] Tony you
are just out of turn to call MAA
America's Hamas who [__] out of here
they are there's your proof and he's got
a [__] video of what he said right
which again I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
play he's got a really he sounds stupid
not only does he say stupid [__] this
guy sounds stupid I mean if you want me
to play it I'll play it but I really I
don't see it being relevant I really
want to show you what he typed out more
than what he [__] said because it's
all Traer this Traer that you know what
I mean
he's like this is how we be traitors we
love treason all that kind of [__] like
and we love treasonist
Trump that's what he's doing the whole
time um it said hundreds of thousands of
peaceful Patriots exercised their First
Amendment right to protest against a
corrupt regime and stole the
presidency again more delusion and More
Lies it's not your First Amendment right
to break into the capital bust down
Windows and threaten the lives of
lawmakers when they're trying to certify
certify a vote that the states the
states already certified see these
[__] idiots are always like oh see
the Democrats and the lefties want to
get rid of the Electoral College so that
way they can rig the vote well if if you
love The Electoral College so goddamn
much why did you guys try to stop
it the electoral votes were certified in
the States you [__] dumb
shits such [__] idiots they don't
even make any sense
he goes on Trump is the first Republican
to make election fraud a top priority
and that's why he's leading in the polls
by 50 plus points
holy [__] isn't the delusion killer now
when I say MAA is America's Hamas what I
mean is is they're [__] spreading
lies and propaganda to their base to get
them to believe just the most ridiculous
[__]
[__] how do you think that Hamas
convinces Palestinians that they are
their protectors huh how do you think
they do it with lies they do it with
propaganda that's how Hamas the
terrorist organization gets Palestinians
a group of Palestinians in Gala City to
believe their [__] just like Maga
uses lies and propaganda to get
Americans to believe their lies and
their [__] so they'll go to I don't
know the capital on January 6 which this
guy who is Big manga Ultra manga says it
is his greatest memory of
trump to go commit domestic terrorism
they lock them the [__] up folks I don't
know if you know this the proud boys the
oathkeepers the leaderships of those
group got terrorist terrorist upgrades
on their Federal sentences of
sedition
Maga is American Hamas got it know it
spread it tell it it's the [__] truth
you don't believe me here we go we will
not stop until we
destroy the election fraud
cartel and make America free country
once again if you don't [__] know
what the kind of propaganda Hamas tells
Palestinians to hate Jewish people and
to hate Israelis and commit violence
against them it is this type of [__]
right here okay you got it are you clear
on it hey when you tell me to delete a
tweet because I called [__] MAA
American Hamas you can go [__] off I'm
not gonna do it I don't care if you're a
loyal Watcher I don't care if you
believe half the [__] I say or 90% of
what I say don't tell me to delete a
tweet that is absolutely 100% true and
I'm giving you the proof right here I'll
continue to give it to you every day
here's how I'm going to do it on Twitter
on Twitter I'm going to post this
picture of it above the Tweet I'm going
to quote tweet and say here's your daily
reminder that manga is America's Zas
that's what we're going to do that's
what we're going to
do that's what we're going to do now
what does that mean what does that mean
well Tony I know someone who's a Donald
Trump supporter but they're not a
terrorist well I mean I I know I I'm
sure that you could find Palestinians
that aren't boned up on Hamas and they
might be like well I don't know I to
some degree I think Kamas is protecting
Palestinians
right that doesn't mean that that
Palestinian is a domestic terrorist
right or a
terrorist these all things can be
[__]
true do you got it do you see it do you
see why the media you know what and I I
I I really hate the last few days I
haven't been able to listen to [__] I
haven't been able to listen to [__]
MSNBC because they keep bringing people
on Israelis on and talking about how
their family members have been [__]
murdered and they're kidnapped and all
that [__] oh my God why the media
continues to do that [__] they're only
breeding more [__] discouragement
they're only breeding more
disengagement why are you breeding
disengagement in in in this in the in
the the battle that Israel is in with
Hamas why why why are you doing that why
why are you breeding disengagement the
the world needs to
engage and we need to [__] sort this
[__] out even in our country we need to
sort out what's right what's wrong who's
right who's wrong and we need to talk
about this [__] we need to be able to
engage each other we need to be able to
have conversations about this I watched
a [__] video of stinny horer the
other day and and Benny Johnson posted
as if it was some kind of burn because
Rasheed Talib had had a had a
Palestinian flag and a and a and lgbtq
flag which those two things do not
compute right they don't and I agree
that t is kind of a little off her
balance there to have those two flags
next to each other it truly is it truly
is off balance a little bit it's like
when a Maglite has the Confederate flag
and the American flag right next to each
other it's it's kind of off balance it
doesn't make a lot of sense okay same
[__] same kind of [__] it's okay to
point that out it's okay to point that
out now it's also okay to say it is it
is tb's absolute [__] right as an
American citizen and as a congress
person to have those two flags next to
each other it is her absolute [__]
right just like it's the right of Maga
to do a dumb thing like having a
Confederate flag and an American flag
next to each other that's their right
it's their [__] right it's dumb it's
dog [__] it doesn't make any [__]
sense it really is kind of backwards if
you want to know the honest truth but
it's their right you have the right to
be [__] stupid in this country trust
me look at this [__] idiot right here
DC Dro oh God he use he exercises his
right to be a dumb [__] every goddamn
day of the
week this guy does not lack the ability
to use his right to be a dumb son of a
[__] but it's the truth what do you
want want it from me it's the [__]
truth so there you have it there's your
proof and I'll keep providing it so and
I'm probably going to do it on Twitter
I'm probably not going to do it on every
single platform Jesus Christ I'm only
one person I can't I can't uh you know
post on every single platform so I'm
kind of leaving it up to you if you want
that picture of that like that daily
reminder picture you know maybe I'll
post it somewhere or you just go to
Twitter you just grab that son of a
[__] I I think I put it on my Instagram
I put it on the Facebook so if you want
that image go get it and then you start
posting it you post it instead of me you
post it where you when you find some
[__] sh garbage post about how they
want to be treasonous and how they're
[__] terrorist right on social media
Facebook Instagram wherever just post
that [__] picture just post that
picture that'll be
suffice just post the image of my tweet
that'll help him out you know what I
mean and it helps me out because then I
don't have to go to every goddamn
platform and again you can just you just
go to this this this tweet right here if
you go to Twitter you just pull this
image or you can go screenshot the Tweet
here I I'll I'll retweet it there you go
I'll retweet it so it's at the top of
the feed now you can go grab
it what else do we get what other video
clips we haven't shown a lot of video
clips today because I don't you know I
really don't need to have a lot of video
clips to show U let's see here oh yeah I
think there was more news um from
U Hansen there another clip of that I'll
probably wait for tomorrow for that
because we're getting into the top of
the hour here
um let's see what else did I have that I
wanted to show you today I thought there
was another one oh yes oh yes yes there
was Charlie Kirk here's another [__]
Putin cck
so so um Charlie's really concerned now
you know did give you a little
background on Charlie's losses here
lately Charlie Kirk has been freaking
the [__] out about RFK Jr at first he
loved RFK Jr right because he thought
that was the perfect [__] candidate
the perfect [__] narrative to beat up
Joe Biden and then they figured out that
it was a rake that they totally [__]
jumped on and that RFK Jr is definitely
100% going to get antib vote which is
not which is not people who are going to
[__] probably vote for
Biden because most people who got the
vaccine know that they they it's okay
it's cool no big deal it's it's all
right I don't have the [__] fake
social media shakes remember those
videos a couple months ago you remember
that [__] they'd be like on social media
and they're shaking acting like they got
the shakes from the [__] vaccine and
it clearly is not not shakes or seizures
at all like they don't even understand
how seizures work like they didn't go
look up what a seizure looks like before
they tried to you know pretend to be
have a
seizure because of the vaccine you
remember that and then the rest of every
all of America looked at them and were
like I I got the vaccine I'm I'm
perfectly fine I'm perfectly fine like
everything's cool everything's good uh
and then they got RFK involved right and
Charlie really my God he really wanted
RFK to some sort of [__] you know
ground to beat Joe Biden on and that
didn't work out but they really
platformed
him and they showed him to Their
audience who is just absolutely vly
antivaccine because they believe all
that stupid ass propaganda all the
[__] lies that MAA tells them about
the vaccine even lies about Trump at the
santis it's [__] weird [__] but they
believe all of
it what Charlie Kirk didn't count on
is that an idiot like RFK Jr would
believe his own [__] I don't know
how they didn't see this so like this
[__] guy believes wild crazy
conspiracy theories even the [__] that
we say he believes that stuff so I don't
know why they didn't think he'd believe
his own [__] but now Charlie is
trying to convince his audience of why
it's bad that RFK Jr is running so now
he's trying to [__] say the opposite
which is really it's wild and now he's
trying to have to tell his audience why
Israel is not Ukraine
and he goes on this long di tribe you
know about how and basically just
projection and lies and [__] and he
continues to lie and [__] his
audience because folks when Charlie Kirk
is tweeting like this he's not tweeting
at us he's tweeting in his [__]
brainless incel Army like like Shaz like
sh I'm sure Shaz [__] loves Charlie
oh I'm loves Charlie loves Charlie
Charlie you know what Charlie's a good
guy you know why Charlie's a good guy he
used turning points USA money to bust
insurrectionists to the capital on
January 6 he made sure to provide
transportation for those domestic
terrorists that try to overturn our
government that Charlie's a swell guy
I'm sure that's what people like Shaz
think about Charlie 100% I don't know if
he's still here he's probably not he
probably he probably got he probably got
he got sick and
tired of uh rage wanking so you had to
go wank to some kind of porn on on
PornHub that he claims he doesn't like
okay all right Shaz
um and here here it is here's the end
I'm not advocating for direct us
involvement but strategically this this
much is clear Israel can win because
here's his argument in this stupid tweet
if you want to read it which I'm not
going to read it to you because it's
really stupid um what he claims is the
reason why America should back Israel is
because Israel can win the it can win
the conflict with Hamas the reason why
America sh I mean it's the exact same
thing like Russia gives money to Iran
Iran gives money to Hamas Hamas [__]
murdered Israelis
right
um but here's the thing Charlie believes
that if there's no chance if you just
believe that you're not GNA win a
war if you if you just
believe that you're not going to win a
war then you shouldn't back them right
so like let's say Israel couldn't beat
Hamas that was our view of it like
there's no way that Israel could could
get rid of Hamas or beat them or or get
to a point to where they have a
ceasefire and they have you know some
sort of peace agreement to some degree
for a certain period of time if Charlie
Charlie believed that that wasn't
possible then [__] it just let Hamas
just kill Israelis just let the
terrorist win just let the murderous
[__] go in and just kill people
just do that that's what he believes
about Russia literally he's like because
Ukraine doesn't seem like they can win
even though they'll fight because
ukrainians have proved that they're
going to fight for their country even if
they can't win Charlie then we shouldn't
support them that's literally the
argument in the [__] thing crazy [__]
man crazy ass [__] that's his argument
uh we're gonna have Gabe Sanchez coming
up here that's right what was that live
with Gabe Sanchez right after this show
here on YouTube and twitch so if you're
on YouTube and you're on Twitch you're
gonna get a chance to swing right over
to Gabe
Sanchez's what was that live uh it looks
like he's gonna be talking about um
fonny Willis and Jim Jordan today Jim I
don't report six crimes
Jordan looks like what Gabe's goingon to
be talking about today so if you're
tuned in here on the Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube or twitch you're G to
want to stick around for another hour
Gabe Sanchez will be right after this
show when I cut away here from YouTube
and twitch you'll go directly
to his channel and his video and his
what was that live if you're on Facebook
though you're gonna have to come over to
YouTube or twitch I've tried to convince
him to get a Facebook page I just I I
promise you I have I really have I
really tried hard to get him to get a
Facebook page you guys can try you guys
probably be more successful than I would
I mean I'm gonna be honest I don't
exactly like Facebook as a platform but
man Facebook people are engaged over
there like they man they comment they're
always looking at stuff the fa Facebook
users as far as social media goes
they're always looking at
Facebook that's one thing so uh I want
to tell all the Facebook people thank
you for being here oh my God wait a
second wait a second uhoh uhoh oh no
here we
go is with the last
name here you hear that you hear the
music here we
go
game
s Cheeto chop Cheeto chop Cheeto chop
Cheeto chop Cheeto chop Cheeto chop
Cheeto
chop Cheeto chop Cheeto chop Cheeto chop
Cheetos Cheeto Cheeto chop Cheeto chop
all right that's enough yeah okay that's
a pretty good entrance was that better
than yesterday I don't know that was
pretty good that pretty good I knew well
I knew what to expect this time
yesterday I was like what is happening
did it catch you off guard okay so I
want I want everyone to know and I I
don't know if you know this but um that
music is Gabe Sanchez's entry music um
whenever he comes on the show um and it
was it was actually it actually made uh
by small rats and skip over on Discord
so yeah they just skip skipped just I
think this morning or light last night I
forget but uh they sent he sent me the
um the song and I was like this is
amazing because yesterday was the first
time I heard it yeah I know well well I
mean it was it's kind of this it's kind
of a version of of a video that we
showed months ago when you were when you
were in a Twitter space with Seb Gorka
and seb's like who's this guy with the
last name last name Sanchez and that's
where it all comes from so if you're
listening and you're like where did that
music come from it actually deres from a
Twitter space that Gabe was in and Seb
Goro was trying to be racist as [__]
like passive racist and he's like who's
this I literally Seb said who's this guy
with the last name
Sanchez yeah said that [__] so he's like
and that's when I said love you Seb yeah
like literally literally Seb gor is like
who's this Mexican in this Twitter space
like who is this who is this guy he
doesn't have the real rights of an
American says the guy who's from [__]
Hungary right who isn't actually born
from America so real quick before you go
because I don't know if you're G to
cover this I kind of laughed at this and
I know you sent this to me yesterday
that um Jank Jank off uh Jank is that
his name Jank off J off yeah Jen off
from t
he's gonna run for president but he's
not actually an americ he's a
naturalized citizen so there's that
whole thing
right I'll talk like briefly about what
are you gonna go over today I noticed
your thumbnail has said Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan yeah yeah so
I'm gonna talk about uh him getting Jim
Jordan getting owned by fonnie Willis
I'm gonna talk about uh this revisionist
storytelling of Nancy mace which I will
do what was that on and I'm going to
expose a lot of the [__] that she said
in the past and now she's like what I
don't know about Matt Gates I don't know
about Jim Jordan all these things even
though Nancy mace made jokes about it in
February oh so she act oh man they she
didn't future proof stuff as you say
yeah yeah and so with that I'm also GNA
cover Israel uh and I've also got some
clips from some creators who are from uh
either the Jewish Community or the black
community just to help people understand
because I I talked about a little bit
about it yesterday which is like look if
you're not an expert that's fine I'm not
an expert but this is one of those
moments where you lean on the people who
are it's complicated right yeah it is
very complicated it's very dense it's a
lot of people are like oh what I I don't
want to deal with it anyway uh uh staral
says no Grizzly stuff right no no no no
this is just like people talking about
the issue and explaining so that you can
better understand good so yeah so I will
talk about that I'm G to jump off I will
see you get your ass over there couple
minutes get the hell out of here see you
see you later with the last name
Sanchez so stick around here on YouTube
and on Twitch if you're on Facebook go
over to YouTube and twitch and just like
get in the chat with gab say open a
Facebook page open a Facebook page open
a Facebook page I bet you can convince
him to do it I can't but I'm GNA try to
convince you to come here tomorrow same
time same place noon Eastern 11 Central
9 Pacific as we do every single weekday
Monday
through Friday two full
hours until next time same time same
place serves up
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events in
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking
that